Pronto, mais ou menos a mesma coisa.
Eu estou me sentindo bem.
Fui bem acolhida.
só estou, pronto, um bocadinho preocupada para o resultado que lá vem.
É mesmo só essa ansiosa, ansiosa, pode mais depressa melhor, pode mais depressa isto, pode mais depressa sai, mas é mesmo, a preocupação é mesmo o cuidado e o pós, o que é que vai vir a seguir, vai correr tudo bem, é certo, mas não deixa de ser uma cirurgia, não deixa de ser...
tirar um bocadinho de mim e o resultado que vem de lá.
Mas pronto, é só isso.
Se eu não tivesse estado com os óculos, é mais fácil assim.
Se eu agora não estar com os óculos, e esse cara está focado noutras questões, ou noutros assuntos, ou até mesmo na cirurgia, que é uma coisa que eu acho que a gente agora tem que tentar um bocadinho esquecer.
Não é que não seja importante, mas lá está.
Para não provocar a ansiedade e o nervosismo, acho que a gente tem que tentar...
passar um bocadinho ao lado e tentar pensar em outras coisas que não a cirurgia.